lundi 31 janvier le petit poucet
versailles est fixé sur son sort le club
yvelinois affrontera l'extérieur
bergerac en quarts de finale de la coupe
de france un autre pensionnaire du
championnat de nationale 2 un adversaire
pas forcément espérer au-delà de jouer
bergerac on est surtout triste de devoir
recevoir pour notre public ça reste un
match de coupe quand même mais c'est
surtout une place qui jouant pour la
demi finale et on va tout donner de
façon on se dit que tout est possible
pour aller en demi finale mais avant de
penser à ce match historique pour le
club versailles et les hommes de
l'entraîneur youssef chibi reçoivent
guingamp au stade mob auront l'occasion
de préparer au mieux le match de coupe
cette 17e journée de nationale 2 débute
bien pour les joueurs locaux avec cette
magnifique frappe de la recrue hivernale
johan brun la 17e minute de jeu 1-0 puis
tant qu'on a chance 1 après le gardien
une fin un petit cadeau aussi parce
qu'il est sur la trajectoire existent
seront un peu voilà j'ai pris ma chance
ça m'a réussi mais la machine se grippe
guingamp égalise sur cette action juste
avant la pause versailles réagi en
seconde période le club se procure des
occasions et touchera les montants mais
ne marquera pas score final 1 partout
malheureusement nous a manqué cette
cette qualité dans la finition qu'avec
un poteau une barre des situations
arrêté par l'adversaire on n'a pas pour
n'a pas pu je dirais traduire le bon
comportement des garçons au coup de
sifflet final les yvelinois se projeter
déjà sur le match contre bergerac japon
va essayer de récupérer à la récupérer
pour rejouer mercredi donc va fort
switcher dans nos têtes pour passer aux
quarts de finale et tout faire pour
essayer d'aller accrocher une demi
finale de coupe de france va s'attacher
à se reposer dès demain pour ensuite
ouvrir la parenthèse coupe de france dès
lundi il se préparer au mieux pour cette
rencontre mercredi on a une semaine
assez chargé avec trois matches à nous
de faire en sorte de de revenir avec
avec des points et du sourire
[Musique]
ce lundi 7 février avant dernier
entraînement au stade de porchefontaine
avant le grand départ pour périgueux
sous le soleil dans une ambiance
détendue mais studieuse le staff est
revenu sur le match de ce week-end
contre guingamp avant de procéder un
décrassage des joueurs sont pas encore
dans le dans le stress aidant et dans la
préparation et la concentration du match
non c'est un peu oui c'est un peu une
une remise en jambes une un entraînement
un peu ludique pour récupérer du match
de samedi et puis se préparer dans la
bonne humeur des jeux
au match qui nous attend donc heureux et
c'est une un petit intermède entre entre
deux matches l'occasion également pour
les joueurs de se mettre dans leur bulle
face à l'engouement médiatique d'un tel
événement cinq seront progressivement
après moi je vais pas aller marcher dans
toutes les villes de me rendre compte de
l'engouement mais en tout cas au niveau
de mes proches je sens qu'il ya de
l'engouement qui qui met donc quand vous
voyez sur les arrêts de bus et même des
affiches un peu par rapport aux coûts
bon moi je de coupe de france donc voilà
ça monte progressivement et on va
essayer de faire perdurer cet engouement
les versailles et partiront ce mardi 8
février en train direction bordeaux il
prendra ensuite un bus pour aller à
périgueux un périple avec un objectif en
tête marquer encore un peu plus
l'histoire des yvelines jamais un club
du département n'avait atteint un quart
de finale de coupe de france